- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Lily Ma
and my one word is extraordinary.
I believe that every
single human being is capable
of extraordinary things.
So to hep you on your journey,
today's message is have
a champion's mindset.
Over to you, Conor McGregor.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I mean you're enjoying
great riches and success
now but can you put
yourself in the mindset
of the guy who's waiting in line
with other people.
- Always, always.
- Do you remember what
that guy was thinking,
we're you day dreaming of this?
Was that even possible
to day dream?
- Every second of every day
I was day dreaming.
But of course I can go
back and think there.
I lived there,
I'd always be there.
I show up and work every single day
like I'm not in the position I'm in.
Like I'm not me.
So that's the mindset I have
and it's work.
- In my opinion,
having a champion's mindset
is having the balance between
not being complacent with your success
and being grateful for your success.
So I think about myself
every single morning I wake up
with the intention
that today is going to be
my hardest working day yet.
If I have succeeded in something,
I'm going to push through
and set higher goals for myself.
Set my standards even higher and continue
to work harder every
single day towards my goal.
How can I be a better coach,
how can I be a better speaker?
How can I be a better speaker?
How can I bring more value to everyone
that comes into my life?
But on the other side,
I am very grateful to have
all the opportunities
that are given to me.
I am grateful to be standing here
speaking in front of this camera
to all of you.
I am grateful to be able to be a coach
where I can help others.
So knowing the balance
between the two has really helped
me with my success,
but also with my fulfillment.
I wasn't always like this.
I was more on the side
of being achievement oriented,
driven, hard work
and constantly grinding out, grinding out
day after day.
And I found myself really depressed
even though I was having
all of these success in my life
I never took a moment to
really appreciate them.
And as a result, I became
really upset with who I became
which is what made me learn
the lesson of gratitude.
You have to take a moment
and really be grateful for
all the things that are coming your way.
As much as I want to be a better coach,
I'm already better
than I was a year ago.
Being grateful for that
gives me the fulfillment
to go ahead and do amazing
things with my life.
And that is why having
a champion's mindset is
about having the balance
between the two.
Both not being complacent
and being grateful all at the same time.
The question of the day is,
what is that one big goal you have
and what is that one thing
that you're really grateful for?
Please write in the comments below
and I'll join in on the discussion.
I have a special shout out
for Marvin Galvan Jr.
Thank you so much for picking
up a copy of Evan's book
Your One Word.
And I really hope you're
enjoying the read.
So thank you so much for watching
We believe in you and I hope you
continue to believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for
another sot of Intspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- The champion's mindset
I think a lot of people
hear the word champion
they think of a famous sports star.
You might think of, in the US they might
think of Michael Jordan
or Lebron James going
and dunking on somebody.
But, we think of it differently.
We think of it as well
when you get on the field,
put everything you have into it.
Put every ounce of energy
you have on the field.
Leave nothing on the field.
And two, when you get knocked down,
'cause if you're an entrepreneur
inevitably you will be.
When you see hard times
and you get knocked down
get back up.
And if you keep putting
everything you got into it
and you keep getting back up
when you get knocked down
it's almost impossible to fail.
- Something you said,
that you're reaching your peak.
Do you think though
you can still take it to another level
or do you think this is
as good as it gets for you?
- Well, I like to
use one quote that "the limitations
exist only in our minds and if you start
using imagination,
then your possibilities
become limitless."
So, that's kind of a mindset that I have,
I use my imagination,
I do see myself achieving more,
I'm hoping, I'm working hard on it.
Not only myself but entire team around me.
- And the core business development system
in any company and every company
sitting here, no matter what kind
of company it is,
is lead generation,
lead conversion, client fulfillment.
How many people do
you attract to your door,
how do you convert a larger and larger
percentage of those people
to become customers and how do you convert
the largest percentage of those customers
to become clients?
And the ball game
of that is mindset.
It's truly the paradigm through which you
approach the building of the systems
through which leadership
and entrepreneurship
becomes a reality every
single day in the company.